what's going on everybody
so we think that a huge breakthrough has
been made with the Russo brothers
cryptic photo that they posted not too
long ago so if you're not caught up a
few days ago the Russo brothers posted
this photo with the caption look hard of
course the internet was sent into a
frenzy and everybody got to work
decrypting this photo and then one
Reddit user cuttlebug actually found
that this machine is actually an
Avengers infinity war where Rhodey is
talking to Ross and then of course the
question arose well what is this there
was a lot of different thoughts but many
people believe that it is actually a
quantum tunnel a small one like the one
in the back of the van and the post
credit scene of Ant Man and the wasp
however we actually think that we've got
it figured out and we do not think that
it is a quantum tunnel at all a buddy of
mine and fellow Marvel youtuber Michael
at everything always actually realized
that this looks a heck of a lot like war
machines and Iron Man's proton cannon
from Marvel vs. Capcom he was actually
the first person to do a video on this
and figure it out so I'll link the
original video that he did in the
description below so be sure to jump
over to everything always and check out
that original video I'm also giving away
a few copies of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray some special edition posters and
some special memorabilia all you have to
do to enter is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so if you're unfamiliar with
the proton cannon it is a massive weapon
that we first saw when war machine used
it in Marvel vs. Capcom it was one of
war machines and Iron Man's hyper combos
and the damage that came from it was
ridiculous
so let's take a look at this photo right
here that comes from at MCU underscore
tweets that is really a combination of
three different photos and as you can
see in the top two photos this is
clearly the same machine I don't think
there's any argument about that so now
let's look at the very bottom photo it
does really look like the proton cannon
we can also see a 3d version of Ironman
wildung this in Marvel vs. Capcom 3 and
it does still really look a lot like
this machine we can also take a look at
the comic version which is from Iron Man
2 94 which was the original appearance
of the proton cannon so again it really
does look like this machine and also
let's go back to some leaked concept art
that we got for Avengers 4 not too long
ago we have this photo where it shows
all the remaining Avengers and a lot of
them have upgrades and if you look at
war machine you can clearly tell that
he's buffed up now he does have some
upgrades so looking at this photo that
is just him we can tell that he is a lot
bigger and also if you look at the gun
that's mounted on his shoulder it's
usually a Gatling gun and this does not
look like a Gatling gun it actually
looks like it could be some sort of
energy weapon so clearly he's getting
some upgrade at his feet I'm like boom
you're looking for this
and that makes perfect sense because
they know how strong vanos is they went
up against him and lost so they know
that the next time they go up against
him they're going to need to be so much
stronger than they were before because
let's face it it wasn't much of a fight
so we saw this an infinity war so they
were already working on it but seeing as
how they just got their butt kicked by
Thanos finishing the proton cannon which
is a massive weapon would probably
become a huge priority so the question
is can this proton cannon actually
defeat Thanos probably not if Thanos has
one or multiple Infinity stones it
probably won't do much but everything
always and I were talking and we believe
that there is one way that the proton
cannon could significantly help in
defeating Thanos and that is firing the
proton cannon at Captain Marvel that
sounds a little bizarre but one of
Captain Marvel's abilities is the power
to absorb energy and if she absorbs
enough energy her energy blasts have the
power of a nuclear explosion
so imagine war machine and Iron Man
shooting their proton cannons at Captain
Marvel while Thor shoots his lightning
at Captain Marvel and she absorbs all of
this energy and then shoots it at Thanos
now that would do some crazy damage
she's already been said to be the most
powerful hero in the MCU so give her
some energy from Iron Man war machine
and Thor that's most likely enough power
to deliver the final blow to Thanos so
war machines proton cannon and probably
Iron Man's as well he has nanotech he
could probably just imagine it to appear
could both be huge keys to defeating
Thanos again judging by these pictures
it really does look like a proton cannon
and I think the logic for the need of it
is there as well so what do you all
think do you think that this is in fact
a proton cannon
and if it is will it play a huge role in
defeating Thanos I personally think yes
to both but let me know your thoughts in
the comments below don't forget to
subscribe like and comment below to
enter the giveaway I'm doing and as
always thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]